hola de nuevo voy a trabajar en el
problema 7 el problema 7 es en el que
nos quedamos y dicen diana es una
repartidora de periódicos que gana a
pesos al día así que vamos a apuntar lo
aquí lo que gana diana es cada pesos
por otra parte de este dinero que ella
gana acá tercios de pesos al día se
eleva en comprar periódico por cierto
esto es lo que gana por día entonces
vamos a anotarlo aquí por día muy bien
ahora ella se gasta por otra parte acá
entre tres pesos por día pesos por día
en comprar el periódico que va a vender
al día siguiente y todos los demás lo
ahorro ahora lo que nos preguntan es
cuántos días le va a llevar a diana a
ahorrar mil pesos
lo que queremos es cristiana ahorre mil
pesos ok ahora si diana gana acá pesos
al día y por otra parte gastaca entre
tres pesos al día cuando ahorran cuánto
le queda a diana de ahorros el ahorro
por día pues va a ser la diferencia
entre estos dos es decir camps menos
acá entre tres pesos lo cual es si
sacamos el mínimo común múltiplo esto es
33 por una es 33 camps menos can lo cual
me va a dar 2 k entre 3 ok entonces lo
que tiene de ahorro diana es 2 k entre 3
pesos por día pesos por día y yo lo que
quiero saber es en cuántos días le va a
llevar a diana a ahorrar mil pesos es
decir si diana ahorra 2 k entre 3 pesos
al día y yo lo que quiero saber es la
cantidad de días que le va a llevar a
diana a ahorrar mil pesos entonces
realmente tengo una ecuación de primer
grado 2 k entre 3 que es lo que ahora en
un día por la cantidad de días que va
ahorrar esto tiene que ser igual a los
mil pesos que ella quiere ahorrar y
bueno la forma de resolver esto es muy
fácil porque lo que hay que hacer para
despejar
y recuerda que tras lo que voy este
entonces es pasar del otro lado el 2 k
entre 3 y para quitar este 2 k entre 3
lo que hay que hacer es multiplicar por
el recíproco el recíproco estrés entre 2
k voy a multiplicar de este lado por 3
entre 2 camps y de este lado también 3
entre 2 k de tal manera que esto se va
con este este se va con este este se va
con éste que chévere es justo lo que yo
quería y me queda quede es igual a mil
por tres entre dos acá estos dos se
pueden reducir un poco mil entre 2 500 y
entonces 500 por 3 es 1500
sobre camps es decir que a diana le va a
llevar 1500 sobre cada días
a ahorrar los mil pesos y de lujo por
cierto este es el inciso de así que ya
lo tengo aquí y vamos a borrar todo esto
para escribir el problema número 8 y el
problema número 8 tiene una recta
numérica y la verdad yo me siento
bastante emocionado por este problema
porque tiene una recta numérica aunque
realmente no sé por qué
debe de ser un desorden mental o algo
así bueno ya sabes algunas anomalías son
buenas otras malas pero bueno vamos a
dibujar la recta numérica así que aquí
tengo mi recta numérica muy bien déjame
poner que es una recta numérica así que
le voy a hacer dos flechas por aquí
y bueno qué pasa con esta recta numérica
me dan varios puntos primero tengo por
aquí un punto
este va a ser mi punto am después al
ladito de este punto am
tengo al menos 2 aquí lo voy a poner
después por acá tengo al menos 1
y del menos 1 al 0 hay un montón de
puntos así que vamos a ponerlos por aquí
está el punto ven por acá está el punto
p y por acá está el punto c y después
aquí está el 0 muy bien
y ahora nos vamos hasta el 1 el 1 está
por acá
este es el 1 no hay nada entre el 0 y el
1 y después hay dos puntos del 1 al 2
del 1 al 2 hay dos puntos aquí tengo un
punto de iu por acá tengo a un punto q y
por último después del 2 está el punto
y bueno déjame leer el problema el
problema dice así cuáles de los
siguientes puntos en la recta numérica
que acabamos de dibujar puede
representar el resultado de la
multiplicación de la coordenada del
punto p por la coordenada del punto q
perfecto y justo este es un problema
divertido de aproximaciones no es así
así que lo primero que quiero es que
averigüemos más o menos a cuánto
equivale p por q es justo lo que
necesito saber a cuánto equivale
aproximadamente p por q porque realmente
no tenemos los datos exactos de cuánto
equivale tanto a como b como p como
todos los demás así que vamos a jugar a
las aproximaciones me voy a fijar en p
este es uno de los que está involucrados
este punto de aquí que por cierto es
como el punto medio más o menos entre
menos uno y cero así que para quitarnos
de problemas voy a decir que éste
es menos un medio aproximadamente es
menos un medio bueno esto es lo que pasa
con el punto p y además tenemos al punto
q el punto q si te das cuenta está más
cercano a 2 entonces está entre 1 y 2 y
de hecho es como un entero porque está
después de 1 pero un entero y tres
cuartos así que voy a decir que es como
un entero tres cuartos así que vamos a
apuntar los p vale aproximadamente menos
un medio ya éste lo vamos a multiplicar
por un entero tres cuartos por un entero
tres cuartos por un entero tres cuartos
pero bueno como yo no soy fanático de
las fracciones mixtas voy a pasar esto a
fracción impropia entonces me va a
quedar menos un medio menos un medio que
va a multiplicar a su vez
4 por 143 son 77 cuartos y cuanto sexto
menos por más es menos uno por 77 2 por
4 es 8 es decir que mi respuesta
aproximada de b por q es menos 7 octavos
y menos 7 octavos está muy cercano a
menos 8 octavos que es menos 8 octavos
es menos 1 que si nosotros estamos
aproximando el resultado de p / q pues
mi aproximación estaría pues cercano a
este punto pero el punto más cercano a
este punto es b que por cierto es
precisamente mi inciso b
tengo como incisos a b c d y e y date
cuenta que si yo multiplico ape por q
esto aproximadamente es b porque tiene
que ser un poquito más pegado a menos 1
que p porque cuando yo multiplico a pep
por un número que es más grande que uno
esto me va a acercar más hacia la
izquierda así que mi respuesta correcta
es ven y por cierto no puede ser porque
ni siquiera está en mis opciones así que
ya está tenemos aquí el resultado de
esta receta numérica que me gustó mucho
que era el problema número 8 y vamos a
hacer un nuevo problema así que déjenme
borrar esta pantalla que tenemos aquí y
bueno esto estuvo divertidísimo así que
podemos hacer el siguiente problema es
el problema número 9 y el problema
número 9 dice si tengo la expresión 5
james + 2x esto es igual a 23 y además
yo sé que x esta x vale ye más uno
entonces lo que me preguntan es cuánto
vale yen y qué creés este es un sistema
de ecuaciones si te das cuenta tengo dos
ecuaciones con 25 gritas y es un sistema
de ecuaciones que podemos resolver de
una manera
por el método de sustitución si
sustituimos el valor de x que es yemas 1
en esta ecuación vamos a poder encontrar
el valor de g
así que vamos a hacerlo lo primero que
voy a hacer es poner 5 bien esto es
parte de la ecuación que tengo aquí
arriba + 2 por x pero x vale ye más uno
entonces vamos a ponerlo más 2 que
multiplican aie más uno esto es lo que
me dice la ecuación número 2
esto es igual a 23 y ahora vamos a
distribuir este 2 multiplicando a la iss
y al 1 y me queda que 5 james
22 por james 22 por 12 esto es igual a
23 pero qué crees aquí se puede sumar 5
+ 205 y hasta 77 y más 2 esto es igual a
23 y si ahora restó 2 de ambos lados de
la ecuación que me va a quedar bueno
pues este con este se van a ir y me
queda que 7 bien es igual a 23 menos 2
lo cual es 21 y ahora como último paso
si dividido todo entre 7 me va a quedar
que ya es igual a 21 entre 7 lo cual es
3 que por cierto era lo que quería
responder y bueno si no te acordabas de
cómo resolver esto no te preocupes yo
tampoco me acuerdo de cómo resolver
muchas cosas pero es bueno repasar lo
así que vamos a movernos a otro problema
déjenme borrar la pantalla y vamos a
hacer nuestro problema número 10
el problema número 10 que dice lo
siguiente y dice una compañía produce
500 electrodomésticos en su primera
semana así que vamos a ponerlo aquí
semana y en la otra parte
electrodomésticos electrodomésticos muy
bien y yo sé que en la primera semana la
compañía produjo 500 electrodomésticos
muy bien ahora dice en su segunda semana
la empresa recibe una máquina con la que
logra hacer un 50 por ciento más de
electrodomésticos de lo que hizo en la
primera semana así que la segunda semana
produce un 50 por ciento más de estos
500 electrodomésticos que hizo en la
primera semana y nos preguntan cuántos
electrodomésticos produce la compañía en
su segunda semana ahora este problema no
hay ni necesario hacer esta tabla está
muy sencillo porque en la segunda semana
va a ser los 500 electrodomésticos que
en la primera semana y además le vamos a
agregar el 50% de estos 500
electrodomésticos y son un 50% más es
decir más punto 50 el 50% que va a
multiplicar a estos 500
electrodomésticos y bueno pues esto es
muy sencillo me va a quedar 500 más y el
50% de 500 es 250 es la mitad
entonces en total en la segunda semana
va a ser 750 electrodomésticos y ya está
así que creo que estamos ya en tiempo y
fue bastante por hoy así que voy a hacer
los demás ejercicios y problemas en el
siguiente vídeo nos vemos pronto